um
now
another question here last one i'm gonna
do
uh can athletes also from adam by the
way can athletes get around the negative
effects of high sugar consumption
because they are more active uh the
short answer is yes
so
a lot of the met like cardio metabolic
concerns about sugar are largely
related to very high intakes of fructose
aside from just being in very positive
energy balance
but fructose does get a little bit more
consideration a little bit more
attention because fructose is
metabolized uh differently than other
monosaccharides so
fructose uh is mostly metabolized in the
liver which can definitely cause some
issues uh and one of the issues is
there's kind of just like this
bottleneck effect of all these
substrates
going to the liver um you know just this
overload of you know carbohydrate and de
novo lipogenesis occurring there and uh
being in an energy surplus with a
tremendous amount of fructose that's all
kind of going to the liver and not
causing uh great things when it comes to
cardio metabolic health
now
the reason i bring that up is because if
you are physically active and exercising
you know when we look at sedentary folks
that are on a
a very high fructose diet we will see
hepatic
de novo lipogenesis so de novo
lipogenesis in the liver we'll see
increases in
fat storage within the liver
we'll see increases in blood trigly
triglyceride concentrations
and
also an impairment of insulin
sensitivity so those are the types of
cardiometabolic issues that we're
looking at
that's in sedentary folks who are in
positive energy balance with a
pretty notable influx of
really deliberately high fructose
if you are
active exercising that is clearing a lot
of those substrates out of your liver
there's a lot of energy flux going on
substrates are coming in they're being
utilized that's a good thing
substrates come in substrates go out
can't explain that you can't uh and and
i won't
but
there there is a study um that kind of
looked at this exact question um
and if anything the study undersells uh
the safety mechanisms for the typical
healthy active person but the study was
by smash and colleagues in 2020 titled
metabolic effects of a prolonged very
high dose dietary fructose challenge and
healthy subjects and that's when you
know that it's a pretty serious
intervention when they're not even
calling it a high fructose diet it's a
high fructose challenge that means the
fructose is pretty high so in this
particular study they were looking at
150 grams of fructose daily
which would be like 300 grams of table
sugar on a daily basis
the fructose equivalent
uh
looked at 10 healthy subjects
after eight weeks of adhering to this
that's a pretty substantial amount of
time
to have that much fructose and these are
are healthy folks but they're not like
you know
running 15 miles a week or anything like
that just healthy folks who are not
deliberately eating in a you know a
caloric surplus
and
basically body weight decreased slightly
during the study
none of the outcomes they looked at
related to
the liver or metabolic health were
significantly impacted in a negative way
so if you have um you know
if your body composition is within a
healthy range for you
and you're
quite active and you're not in a large
energy surplus
you know
dealing with sugar even if it's pure
fructose in this example doesn't seem to
be uh
much of a challenge at all doesn't seem
to be much of a problem so
uh esp for someone who's relatively lean
and exercising regularly uh it is really
not something that is worth uh
being too concerned about as long as
sugar's not displacing other important
stuff from your diet but you know the
the anecdotal evidence for this is quite
abundant as well um
i don't know many people who have more
sugar than the typical endurance athlete
who's putting in pretty high mileage um
you know we're not seeing a lot of
endurance athletes coming in with you
know non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
or you know metabolic syndrome or things
like that so absolutely
if you're active and especially if you
maintain relatively lean body
composition and you're not in a huge
caloric surplus
you can certainly get around some of
those negative effects of high sugar
consumption